so did President Trump try to fire
Robert Mueller and if so does it matter
plus the Trump administration rolls out
its big immigration plan and people on
both sides are unhappy and we'll go to
the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so here we are and it's
finally a Friday time has moved so
slowly that let me remind you the
government shutdown ended on Monday okay
bleep Holgate started 14 days ago we
have now gone down to the water planet
and interstellar where every hour is
actually seven years of time and we are
stuck there because every day is at
least seven seventy-three news cycles
but the good news is that gives us a lot
to talk about and we'll get to all of it
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Birch gold so if things
feel relatively uncertain even with the
economy as good as it is the fact is
that you need to diversify you need at
least some of your money in precious
metals Birch gold group is a
long-standing track record of continued
success thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau and if
you contact Birch gold group right now
you get a free information kit on
physical precious metals it's a great
hedge against inflation one of the
reasons people are investing in Bitcoin
is because they don't trust the
government manipulation of the currency
while owning precious metals also hedges
your bets against that sort of thing
they will send you this comprehensive 16
page kit revealing how gold and silver
can protect your savings how you can
legally move your IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit go to www.google.com
slash Ben that's birchgold.com slash Ben
check it out
birchgold.com slash Ben and again
they're the people who I would trust
make sure you ask all your questions
make sure that you get all your answers
and then when you're ready to invest in
precious metals birchgold.com slash bad
news that slash Ben so that they know
that we sent you okay so the big
breaking news of the day is of course
this big New York Times report that back
in June of 2017 President Trump tried to
fire Robert Mueller so according to
Muller I looked it up it's now smaller
okay I'm getting it wrong for months
it's Muller okay so hover Muller is of
course the special investigator who's
appointed in June 2017
after president from fired James Comey
and then after he used a Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein in the process of
doing it forcing Rosenstein to recuse
himself in the Trump Russia collusion
investigation and turned the whole thing
over to a special investigator Jeff
Sessions did not protect from because
he'd recused himself Rosenstein didn't
protect Trump cuz he had to recuse
himself because of the Comey firing and
now it looks as though Muller as I've
been saying for at least several weeks
is moving from
- obstruction now the problem with the
obstruction of justice case is that in
order to actually say that somebody's
obstructed justice you actually need to
fulfill one of three laws and I'm going
through the three laws a couple of times
explaining what exactly these three laws
mean because there are three different
statues statutes but let's go through
them again because I think that we need
to have this clear in our mind when
people say that some sort of criminal
activity went forward or that robert
muller is going to get trump there's two
ways to get Trump one is to hit him so
hard politically the Democrats have a
reason to impeach and the other is to
actually suggest criminal obstruction of
justice as I say there are three types
of obstruction of justice under the US
law 18 US Code 1503 I'm going through
his background again we did it a little
earlier this week but I think it's
important the Omnibus Clause covers
corruptly or by any threatening letter
or communication influencing or impeding
or endeavoring to influence obstruct or
impede the due administration of justice
so the clause requires a pending
judicial proceeding so that means that
Trump would pursue it like an FBI
investigation isn't enough would be him
trying to bribe a prosecutor or
something the Supreme Court is pretty
exacting on the application of the law
the prosecutor would actually need to
prove that Trump's conduct materially
impeded the investigation even James
Comey said when he was fired afterward
that Trump did not materially impede the
investigation so if it is true that
Trump tried to fire robber Muller the
special investigator then that still is
not materially impeding the
investigation so this part of the code
is probably not being fulfilled then
there is 18 US Code 1512 C this
provision of law covers anyone who
obstructs influences or impedes an
official proceeding or attempts to do so
so there are a few questions about this
one is an FBI investigation and official
proceeding - you actually have to prove
criminal intent you have to prove that
Trump wanted to impede the investigation
now this would be the area of the code
where Trump would be in the most trouble
but you also have to show that you took
a substantial step toward the
accomplishment of that goal toward an
accomplishment of an attempt to obstruct
justice I'm not sure that that's fulfill
a ball because again even if Trump
wanted to fire Muller and even if you
think that would constitute obstruction
he withdrew that he didn't actually fire
Muller and when he fired Comey
he had every right to do that you can
fire your FBI director for any reason
whatsoever so the idea that that is
technical obstruction of justice is
pretty weak it would be very difficult
to convicting a but in the court of
public opinion there is a different
problem right so here is the story from
the New York Times with all that in mind
but the fact that there is a section of
the US code that theoretically might be
applied against Trump maybe although
you'd have to explain why it is that he
doesn't have the executive authority
just to fire fire Muller or fire Comey
for any reason at all
obstruction of justice by the way my
president would look not like him firing
somebody it would and then letting the
investigation continue it would look
more like him going to Robert Muller and
saying you will find me innocent or I
will fire you right those are the two
choices you'll find me innocent Rio
fiery that would be obstruction of
justice for him just to say I don't like
this investigation and bothers me you're
fired not quite sure that that is
obstruction of justice particularly if
the investigation continues afterward
anyway the New York Times broke this
story so I say back in June 2017 as it
became clear that Special Counsel Robert
Muller was looking for a pattern of
possible obstruction of justice in
Trump's behavior Trump ordered Muller
fired
he only retracted the order when white
House Counsel Don Magan threatened to
quit so according to The Times report
Trump said that Muller had a bunch of
different conflicts of interest and you
can tell that this report is probably
true because of what Trump said was the
conflict of interest conflict of
interest number one according to Trump
was that Muller had resigned his
membership had the trump National Golf
Club in Sterling Virginia years ago over
a dispute over membership fees that is
not a conflict of interest again that's
that silly second Trump said Muller
could not be impartial because his law
firm had represented Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner again that is not really a
thing right law firms law firms
represent lots of people if if Muller
didn't work on that case it probably
wouldn't matter so an a-plus if you're
talking conflicts of interest Trump was
interviewing Muller as a possible FBI
director before Muller took the special
counsel job finally Trump's and Muller
had been had been up for the FBI
Director position before he was
appointed special counsel it's unclear
why that would actually be a conflict of
interest okay fine so The Times reports
after receiving the president's word
afire Muller the White House Counsel Don
Magan refused to ask the Justice
Department to dismiss the special
counsel saying he would quit instead
they spoke on the condition of anonymity
because they did not want to be
identified discussing a continued
investigation
McGann disagreed with the president's
case and told senior White House
officials that firing Muller would have
a catastrophic effect on mr. Trump's
presidency mr. McGann also told the
White House officials that mr. Trump
would not follow through on the
dismissal on his own the president then
backed off that of course was true Trump
has been threatening to fire sessions
for over over a year and I fired him
Trump has been threatening to fire me
he's threatened to fire Magan before
he's threatened fire everybody the truth
is that Trump really doesn't fire anyone
Mike Flynn resigned he wasn't actually
fired so why does this matter number one
it's not what the left cracks it up to
be so he didn't actually fire Muller if
he had fired Muller then we'd be talking
about obstruction of justice it would
look like the Saturday night massacre
the Saturn a massacre going all the way
back to 1973 Watergate is when there was
a special investigator Archibald Cox who
was called in to look at Watergate and
Trump asked his attorney general to fire
Archibald Cox the Attorney General
refused and so Trump fired the Attorney
General sorry Nixon yes and this would
be Nixon back in 1973 so here is it so
here is the so obviously that's not
happening here he didn't fire Muller he
didn't fire his Attorney General he
didn't fire Rosenstein he didn't fire
sessions he hasn't fired he hasn't fired
anybody right so but here's here's what
Muller is going to do he's gonna put
together to the following fact and he's
he's going to say or it could say that
this is an attempt to obstruct justice
the Trump is attempting to skew the
investigation so here are all the things
Trump has done and they're equally
explicable by stupidity as always I tend
to believe the Trump is being an idiot
not Trump is being nefarious story
because I think that mostly Trump is
being an idiot not nefarious so here are
all the things Trump has done first he
fired National Security Advisor Mike
Flynn Trump implied that that was
prompted by FBI lying and Flynn lying to
the FBI
then he reportedly asked FBI director
Comey to lay off of Flynn now if he
asked him to laugh and Flynn knowing
that he had already lied to the FBI is
that obstruction of justice not clearly
because he obviously didn't take any
measures against Comey from February all
the way until May right and Comey
continued to after Flynn the president
then fired Comey and acknowledged
publicly it had to do with the Russia
investigation but he was saying at the
time that it wasn't because he wanted to
stop the investigation it's because he
is innocent and Comey wouldn't say
openly that he was innocent okay the
president then had a continuous stream
of invective against Attorney General
Jeff Sessions for accusing himself on
Russia again is that obstruction of
justice not really the president
attacked Attorney General Deputy
Attorney General Rosenstein attacked
Deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe and
now the parents that the president's
apparent attempt to fire Mueller
now none of this amounts to legal
obstruction probably as I say in the
Salander Schwartz has said the president
is the head of the executive branch the
investigation has not been quieted in
any way so whatever attempts were
happening it's hard to prove attempts
when there was no actual impeding of the
investor
so that is that is point number one when
it comes to this Muller stuff but it's
gonna be used as the left as evidence
that Trump actually wanted to shut down
the investigation and then he wasn't
able to do it and then he failed in
doing so but if he had had his druthers
he would have that's going to be part of
this this broader suggestion by the left
that Trump is trying to obstruct justice
even if there's no hard proof that Trump
is trying to obstruct justice and the
more plausible case is that Trump is
just pissed these people don't say he's
innocent and so he's mouthing off a lot
which I've been saying for months is my
read on the situation okay so in just a
second I'm going to explain another
scandal that is that is afoot and that
of course has to do with the FBI's
treatment of Hillary Clinton but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Zeile comm so if you are
interested in getting a massage right
you're stressed out it's been a long
week it's been a while since since the
holidays and now you just need a massage
this is the great thing about Zeile so
Zeile is the perfect solution for anyone
who wants a high quality massage in the
convenience of their own home you don't
have to go to the spy or enough to
schedule weeks in advance you can just
literally go on their app and order a
licensed masseuse to come to your house
and you can choose style you can choose
the gender of the masseuse and then the
person comes to your house with the
table with the oils with the music they
turn your house into a spa it makes a
great Valentine's Day gift make somebody
give generally it's pretty amazing
so to help you get started our listeners
can get twenty five dollars off their
first massage by using the promo code
been at checkout and it gets even better
if you sign up for zeals massage
membership you get 20% off all your
massages plus a free massage table and
sheet set a $380 value yours free
there's no initiation fee to join the
membership just a great additional
savings on top of the $25 discount
you're gonna get when you use promo code
Ben
so go to zeals eee Elcom or on zeals
iPhone or Android app and then make sure
to click add promo code to check out to
use my code Ben and get that $25 off
your first in-home on-demand massage and
as I say it is a fantastic fantastic
gift I've given it to my wife to my
mother-in-law to my mom to my dad to my
sister so I've given it's pretty much
everybody in the family and I've used it
myself 7 days a week 365 days a year
zeal massage therapists can be at your
door it's just fantastic zeal comm make
sure you use that promo code Ben and
check out and get 25 bucks off your
first in-home on-demand massage okay so
with all of them all our stuff blowing
up the internet with all the Muller
stuff blowing up the the
the TV and and blowing up the New York
Times and blowing up all the media oh my
god he thought about doing something
they didn't knew it which again seems
not supremely scandalous to me there is
something that is supremely scandalous
okay there are new texts between those
anti-trump FBI agents and one of the
reasons that people don't trust the FBI
they don't trust the Intel community on
Trump is because of this sort of stuff
on Thursday night Senator Chuck Grassley
released seven pages of text between FBI
counterintelligence agent Peter struck
and his FBI paramour lisa page those
texts
show that both struck and Paige were
interested in letting Hillary Clinton
off the hook so as to earn the FBI's
goodwill with the presumed next
president so here's what the actual text
said Paige wrote to struck on February
25 2016 this is before the interview
with Hillary Clinton quote one more
thing she might be our next president
the last thing you need us going in
there loaded for bear you think she's
gonna remember or care that it was more
DOJ than FBI the obvious implication go
easy on Hillary she might be the
president and then she might get angry
at the FBI for having interviewed her in
nasty fashion and struck Rebecca green I
called the FBI counterintelligence had
bill pre step and related what we
discussed he agrees I will email you and
redacted and then someone else whose
name is redacted another one of the text
from page two struck suggested that then
FBI chief of staff James ryebeck II
thought that the FBI deputy director
Andrew McCabe who is still own job
should recuse himself from the Clinton
matter because of his wife's
relationship with Virginia Governor
Terry McAuliffe right mccabe has the
recused him as he recused himself in the
he eventually did he can recuse himself
from the Clinton stuff like a week
before the election but I should have
done it months before apparently Paige
wrote quote ryebeck he just called to
check in he very clearly 100% believes
that andy mccabe should be recused
because of the perception so Grassley
wrote a letter to the FBI's current
director Christopher Wren quote in
October 2015 then director Comey said if
you know my folks they don't give a rip
about politics they cared very much
about politics to the detriment of the
bureau's mission and objectivity so all
this is really damning stuff for all the
talk about how the FBI is crystal is
crystal clear transparent absolutely
clean for all of the talk about that
that is just not the case it's just not
the case now does that mean that there's
an FBI deep state coup to take down
Trump no the evidence isn't all there of
that especially because there isn't a
countervailing text message from structu
page saying he didn't want to be staffed
on the Moller investigation
because he thought there was no there
there I think that Chris Wallace is
basically correct when he says that
we're not there on the DP state cou
here's what here's what Wallace said on
Fox News apparently and here is the
Inspector General we only found out
about this in the last week and the
Inspector General was able to come up
with it so again look there's a lot of
things that are troubling there are a
lot of questions to ask I fully agree
that we need to pursue all of this I'm
not sure that talking about deep state
cooze against the president or
corruption at the highest levels of the
FBI I'm not quite sure we're there yet
okay and I think that's probably correct
that's why I've been saying just wait
just wait you know hold in abeyance
there there will be evidence that comes
out on some of this stuff but when every
time everybody jumps ahead of the story
it comes back to bite them right Ron
Johnson being the case in point the
senator from Wisconsin who had been
talking about a secret society inside
the FBI and then yesterday he had to
admit and maybe the secret society stuff
was just a joke text message seems to be
a comment about secret society was
ingest do you agree that it appears to
be it was a just thank you okay so and
that that seems to be a big step down
from the notion that we were all going
to we were all going to find out that
there was this big deep state coup
happening against the the Trump
administration and now with all that
said there's a way to jump in the other
direction too so Shep Smith over on Fox
News who's made a bit of a cottage
industry lately in quote-unquote
debunking his other Fox News colleagues
he's very upset about the Devon Nunez
memo so you remember Devon Nunez the
head of the House Intelligence Committee
and he wrote up a four page memo talking
about improprieties inside the
intelligence agencies that he thinks
discredit a lot of what's happening in
the Trump Russia collusion investigation
now that memo has been made available to
all the members of the House Democrats
are saying it's a politically driven
memo Republicans are saying that is
pretty damning the DOJ is saying that he
hasn't even looked at the underlying
classified documents but they want to
redact it before it's released Andy
McCarthy over national views is really
good on all of this scandal driven stuff
because if he has a very good piece of
our National Review talking about the
Nunes memo and basically saying listen
there's nothing inherently wrong with
Devin Nunes writing a memo it may be as
partisan maybe it's not that's why it's
good for the American public to see it
and as for the notion that the DOJ
hasn't gotten review it in they're very
upset about it in order for this memo to
be declassified the President of the
United States first has to sign off
about on
there's like a five-day delay mechanism
specifically to allow the president to
allow the DOJ to take a look at it and
then Trump can veto any attempt does he
classify this material so it really
isn't quite as corrupt as some people
are making it out to be the memo now
maybe turn out that it's just newton's
attempt to distract from the Trump
Russia collusion
investigation and maybe that it's an
attempt to distract from Muller
investigation that's all quite possible
but we don't know that yet but people
are jumping to conclusions here Shep
Smith jumping to some conclusions this
memo from which there if there is a
basis for it to be released the Trump
the Trump administration and its people
could have done that they've asked to
see it he won't even let them see it it
seems to be a classic weapon of mass
distraction okay and of course the left
was was cheering this a weapon of mass
distraction he's on his own friends own
friends are going around talking about
how how this is a weapon about how the
memo is Shep Smith's own friends with
Fox News are talking to how the memos
the end of the world and here Shep Smith
debunking them what a hero you know I
think everybody is jumping to
conclusions a little bit too quickly
okay in other news when the economy
continues to boom story after story
about companies offering bonuses wage
increases so in breaking news in
literally last couple of minutes FedEx
has now announced 3.2 billion dollars in
wage increases and bonuses this follow
Starbucks announcing raises it's just
Armageddon all over the place remember
Nancy Pelosi said all of this was crumbs
rather the the Democrats continue to
maintain that this was all the end of
the world that everyone is going to die
from the tax cuts and it turns out
everything is going fine right it turns
out that the economy is doing just fine
and all of this was overblown which is
not a shock anyway none of it is really
a shock but it does demonstrate the bad
faith in which so many members of
Congress talk about politics now this is
also breaking news today Adam Schiff the
ranking member of the house permanent
Select Committee on Intelligence
Democratic from California and a very
motivated political actor he said the
reports that the president not only
considered firing special councilor
Muller but went so far as to order it
demonstrate the neck Sounion lengths
this president is prepared to go to
protect himself Congress must make clear
any effort to remove the special counsel
or impede his work would touch off a
constitutional crisis which would
imperil his presidency and do grave
damage to our nation instead of
protecting Muller's investigation
from undue interference many Republicans
in Congress have stepped up their
spurious attacks against the DOJ the FBI
and the special counsel it's time for
them to put country in the rule of law
before party ok Congress should not pass
a law preventing the Special Counsel
from being fired the Special Counsel
works for the executive branch there is
a separations of power in our
Constitution there is a way for Congress
to check the president if the president
gets rid of Keio special councilor
Muller and people in the Congress think
that's corrupt and they think there's an
attempt by Trump to get off the hook
they can impeach him that is the
proscribed constitutional remedy for all
of this it is not a remedy there is no
prescribed constitutional remedy it's in
the notion that the Congress is going to
tell the president who he can and cannot
fire if they don't like I'm firing Comey
they can impeach him if they don't like
I'm firing Muller they can impeach him
but this idea that Congress is going to
step in and now Congress is going to
dictate which executive branch officials
can be fired by the president that's
foolishness because then that person is
not a member of any branch the person
can't be fired by the legislative branch
the person can't be fired by the
president so the person basically is in
their for life well the Congress doesn't
have the power to do that Congress
doesn't have the ability to do that
under the Constitution there is the
separation of powers in the Constitution
like it or not the president does have a
power to do this and that's what
happened with Archibald Cox Nixon did
have the ability to fire Archibald Cox
at least through the Attorney General he
did have the ability to fire the
Attorney General he then put in place
Robert Bork who took over and fired
Archibald Cox he had the ability to do
that and then he was gonna be in Paige
so he quit right so there are
constitutional remedies for all of this
but changing the Constitution in order
to give Congress more power over the
president's ability to fire a special
counsel seems like a foolish a foolish
thing now what's funny is people are
going nuts just to return to the Muller
thing for a second people are going much
more nuts over the Muller stuff that
this new Muller story the Muller was
almost fired back in June then they are
over the struck page text which clearly
suggests that the FBI was thoroughly
corrupt in the Hillary Clinton
investigation that is that I think is
relatively insane again people are on my
case because they're saying well you're
saying that Trump didn't commit a crime
right I'm saying it's not a crime to
consider firing someone in that foot and
then not firing that person that's not
actually a crime so if you're gonna
accuse somebody of a crime you have to
explain why it's a crime you can't just
say it's criminal I and the idea that
this provides intent behind Trump for
obstruction you actually have to
demonstrate how Trump attempted to
obstruct again I have a hard time
believing that Trump is at
tempting to obstruct when literally this
investigation is on the front page of
the newspapers every single day and has
not been obstructed in any serious way
as even James Comey recognized so again
I think that a lot of this is overblown
and I have a feeling a lot more
information is going to come out that
demonstrates that a lot of the
particular accusations that are being
made on both sides tend to be kind of
false okay so in just a second we are
going to discuss you know what let's
just let's go to right now so let's
discuss the new immigration framework so
President Trump has now proposed a new
immigration framework this new
immigration framework is ticking people
off on both sides of the aisle so on the
one side you have Democrats who are
calling him a racist I received an email
last night from one of these one of
these leftist interest groups talking
about how it was just terrible
that Trump was proposing this this
immigration proposal so let's go through
the proposal what exactly is Trump
proposing let's start there so on
Thursday the White House released a
rundown on its new proposal regarding
the handling of illegal immigrants
originally protected under President
Obama's deferred action for childhood
arrivals program that program mandated
that illegal immigrants brought to the
country as children through no fault of
their own register with the government
and in return received papers allowing
work authorization and freedom from
deportation now Trump in an attempt to
push forward a deal with Democrats to
one another government shutdown or to
avoid this this kind of fake deadline on
March 5th he's put together his
framework so here is his framework and
it's making people on the Left crazy and
it's making people on the right crazy so
it says number one there will be full
amnesty for 1.8 million illegal
immigrants now remember only 700,000
illegal immigrants were actually covered
by daca the way daca worked is you had
to register with the government you had
to come forward say I'm an illegal
immigrant I've been here since I was a
kid and then the government gave you
essentially a green card to work in the
country and not be deported Trump is
extending that out to 1.8 million
illegal immigrants so he's almost
tripling that number which is insane
within 10 to 12 years those illegal
immigrants would become full citizens
that number includes as I say both the
700,000 illegal immigrants so-called
dreamers who registered and other
dreamers who did not the White House is
designing this because they say that
this is a big concession to Democrats
what do they want in return for this
rather generous policy well they want 25
billion dollars for a fund for the
border wall which presumably will never
happen you can put a bunch of money in a
fund if it doesn't get spent right away
and the government will just take it
from there and use it somewhere else
like the Social Security trust fund
Republicans would also theoretically
receive an end to chain migration now
chain migration is the leading way that
new legal immigrants come into the
United States so this does this is a
significant limitation on legal
immigration to the United States I think
probably a smart move I think chain
migration the idea that you're here and
you're great therefore we have to bring
your family and is foolish chain
migration would still apply to people
and they would apply to people and their
parents and their immediate minor
children but there is a caveat and this
is what a lot of immigration Hawks are
upset about they're saying that the
delay in the in the revocation of chain
migration means that something like 4
million new illegal immigrants will come
into the country because of chain
migration right this is what Mark
Krikorian points out he says that over
the course of the next 20 years because
there's gonna there's gonna be
grandfathered in because Trump is not
just saying chain migration ends today
he's saying everybody who's on the wait
list gets in that wait lists right now
is something like 17 years long okay the
original immigration Hawk proposal said
that if you're on the waiting list in
you're within a year of getting into the
country then you get to stay on the
waiting list and you get to come into
the country but if you're not then we
will just refund your fee and that will
be the end of chain migration so no
cousins no uncles no grandmothers none
of this stuff we're not gonna let just
random relatives of yours come into the
country if they're a year out from even
having their application considered
that's not in this proposal this
proposal says that if you're on the wait
list right now then you are going to
stay on the wait list so another four
million people will enter the country
that's a pretty massive swath of legal
immigration coming into the country the
visa diversity lottery would also be
ended now Krekorian has been on Twitter
urja encouraging people to burn their
Maggi hats and he explains why over at
National Review here's what he says he
says the white house has about is he and
here's his tweet it's time to start
burning your Maggie hat send pictures in
all retweet so you know he liked getting
calls were very upset about this so he
writes quote the White House has botched
the data issue cutting Bob Goodlatte
House bill off at the knees by blue
glass House bill limited legal
immigration and making it more likely
that there will either be no bill at all
or that the final bill the president
signs which is guaranteed to be even
weaker than this will fatally demoralize
Republican voters in November if the
latter happens the president will be
well on the way to joining Andrew Andrew
Johnson and Bill Clinton the impeach but
not removed club now that's possible
it's possible that Trump is preemptively
surrendering this one a lot of people
are saying
on the right that is a betrayal and
Trump is is allowing two million illegal
immigrants into the country and to do
who are in the country now to get
citizenship plus another four million
legal immigrants into the country and
this is Trump caving and why would he
give away this as his opening bargaining
position the notion here is that Trump
has given away that bargaining position
what he should have said is I'm willing
to deport everyone now Democrats come to
the table so we can make a deal all
right there'll be a stronger bargaining
position and that's possible that's
possible and Democrats are already
trying to rail against Trump as I say
calling Trump a racist I got an email
yesterday from some bizarre immigration
group suggesting that Trump's proposal
was deeply racist again I don't
understand how legalizing two million
illegal immigrants most of whom are not
white is is racist and this is a group
called credo I guess which is credo
action they sent out a letter yesterday
says not surprisingly a racist
immigration fantasy mask as a proposal
from a racist white house is a white
supremacist wish list said credo
political director of merchants that
he'd I mean talk about being
disconnected from reality this proposal
was like a Jeb Bush proposal there's a
marco rubio proposal and they're calling
it a white supremacist fantasy to say
that you want to let formally any
additional immigrants into the country
who are results of chain migration and
you want to legalize two million illegal
immigrants who are currently here and
give them citizenship ten to twelve
years in that does not sound
particularly racist but this is why i
think that people who are suggesting
that Trump is negotiating badly here are
actually getting it wrong so I've said
yesterday I don't think Trump is a good
negotiator but I don't think this is a
negotiation I don't I don't think Trump
is putting out this proposal because
he's actually hoping to reach a
negotiated end point with Democrats I
think Trump is putting out this proposal
because he is posturing for public
consumption
he knows the Democrats are never gonna
make a deal with him he knows the
Democrats will always call him racist he
knows no matter what he says the
Democrats are going to suggest that he
is a racist so if he came out and he
negotiated the way Krekorian wants him
to and he said listen I will deport
everyone now negotiate with me and not
only with Democrats not negotiate with
him they would then say well you're a
racist and that's why you wanted the
port everyone and then come March fifth
Trump would have to reinstate daca
himself and he'd look like a weakling
and a racist right so Trump or at least
his team knows that and so I think
they're doing something else I think
they understand No Deal is in the offing
here there will be no deal
all the people who are talking about a
deal are crazy and they don't what
they're saying okay so here's what I
think is what's happening I think that
Trump is posturing for public
consumption he's trying to demonstrate
how much love he has for illegal
immigrants he's trying to demonstrate
that he is not racist he's saying to
Democrats listen I'm giving you not only
what you want but more than what you
want and you still won't give me border
security
so obviously I'm not a racist I want to
let a bunch of illegal immigrants stay I
was letting more legal immigrants stay
than then Obama would have under daca
right I'm letting all these people stay
even if they didn't apply I'm letting
them stay that's how much I care about
illegal immigrants but I also care about
border security and so here's what I
want in return and Democrats are saying
no we don't care about the dreamers so
we will let them suffer and we would
rather to let them suffer than give you
any sort of border security so this is
political posturing by the president and
I think that it's not particularly
unwise political posturing by the
president there are some members of his
base will remember this proposal but it
is a good counter talking point right
when Democrats say he's racist about
immigration it's pretty easy for him to
say listen I proposed something more
liberal than Barack Obama on immigration
and Democrats turned that down because
they hate the idea of a border wall that
much they turned that down because they
hate the idea of restricting our
immigration system in any way so I think
that this is all Kabuki theater in other
words if you viewed as Kabuki theater
then Trump's proposal here is not a bad
one if you view it as an opening
bargaining position then Trump's
proposal is a bad one if you viewed it
as a final negotiated position I don't
think it's the worst negotiated position
in the world most of the dreamers gonna
say anyway the idea there's gonna be
mass deportations was never true so it
depends on the prism through which you
are viewing this particular immigration
proposal are you viewing it as just a
public relations ploy if so it's smart
if you're viewing it as an open opening
bargaining position it's dumb as
Krekorian and coulter point out and if
you're viewing it as somewhere in
between it's it's sort of what Trump
actually wants it's not the worst
proposal I've ever seen but it is also
not the trumpian Magga Malcolm a guy
Jeff Sessions Stephen Miller immigration
plan that everybody was promised back
during the election cycle okay so in
just a second we are going to get to
some things I like and some things I
hate and then we will also get to the
mailbag but first you're going to have
to subscribe so for $9.99 a month you
can go over to daily wire comm and
become a subscriber when you do that
when you become a subscriber to daily
wear comm you get the rest of my show
live
Clavin show live Knowles's show live you
get to be part of our mailbag right now
like in the next two minutes we're gonna
be in the neck
five minutes we'll be doing the mailbag
get to ask me questions and make your
life eminently better but not only that
on Tuesday January 30th our president is
gonna speak to the nation in his second
State of the Union address President
Trump speaking in front of the entire
nation is the president it'll be wild
and you should watch it with us here at
the Daily wire we are having a full-on
watch party starting 8:00 p.m. Eastern
5:00 p.m. Pacific we'll be hanging out
with you the whole time
leading up to during after the address
we're gonna do the red carpet it'll be
great we're gonna ask what people are
wearing we'll be there for every wild
hand gesture all of the off teleprompter
remarks and of course the hilarious
rebuttal from Democrats you know the
Democrats are using by the way they're
now using Joe Kennedy Joe Kennedy right
like Rob Bobby Kennedy's grandson and
they're saying he's a rising star what's
really fantastic I have to say about
America one of the great things about
America is that anyone can be President
if your last name is Kennedy Clinton
bush or Obama or Trump right you have
Dave you have a famous last name you can
be President so that's that's one thing
I love is it you can out any child who's
born into a really rich family with
famous ancestors can be present in the
United States I mean it really gives you
hope anyway you can catch the live
stream over at Daley wire.com Daley wire
Facebook or Daley where YouTube to spend
the evening with me and Clavin and
Knowles and Daley wire guy came Jeremy
boring and we're gonna relentlessly mock
our government we're gonna mock
political leaders we're gonna mock all
of the all of the pomp and circumstance
which I dramatically hate and also for a
Daily wire subscriber you can ask us
questions during the broadcast we're
going to take those live during the
broadcast which is one of the reasons
you should subscribe again that's
January 30th a p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific follow us at Facebook and
YouTube and get notified when we go live
so we can spend every terrible moment
together and get drunk and my colleagues
will smoke and I will sit there in in
vibing their fumes and dying of lung
cancer it'll be great so check that out
next Tuesday if you want the annual
subscription at all of those things plus
you get this the very greatest in all
tumbler is the leftist here is hot work
called tumblr which you will enjoy
everyone who has it has has increased
their income by double that is not an
actual study and I don't think that's
true but you can try maybe it'll work
for you
who knows correlation may not equal
causation but we can try anyway enough
of that you want to check us out later
go over to iTunes SoundCloud YouTube
subscribe believe it's a review we
always appreciate we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty time for a thing I like and
then a thing that I hate so and then a
few things that I hate actually lots of
things I hate let's get let's get
hateful tonight okay so things I like
and we'll begin we've been doing fantasy
books so I don't think I've recommended
this before but this is one of those
it's it's more along the lines of Alice
in Wonderland it's it's kind of falling
out of favor did you guys read this
growing up this book The Phantom
Tollbooth when I was growing up this was
sort of recommended reading for people
who are in third fourth grade and it's
pretty great by Norman juster it's about
a kid who has to go on a quest but his
quest takes him to all of these kind of
bizarre lands and there's like a math
land and there's a there's a grammar
land and it's but it's it's really fun
and it's really it's really clever I'm a
big fan of the Phantom Tollbooth I
really like this book a lot it's it's
worth getting before your kid if your
kids 87 89 years old or if you're smart
like my kid 4 so in any case the Phantom
Tollbooth by Norton Juster
I'd totally totally worth picking up for
kids great for kids okay time for 1,000
things I hate all right so let us begin
with with CNN so CNN is doling out
marriage advice now one of the things
that CNN New York Times a lot of
publications do now is they put out
pieces in which they suggest that they
know better about marriage than
traditionalist have known forever so now
CNN says that maybe one way to save your
marriage is to get cooked
you know to be a cuckold to let your
partner sleep with another person the
author's David lay Justin Lee Miller and
savage love write of course it stands to
have a jaw of course it's dan savage
savage love writer and activist and
Savage who's always a proponent of
promiscuity they want you to know that
most people who try being a kook finding
a positive and rewarding experience and
that quote acting on cuckolding
fantasies can be a largely positive
experience from any couples and hardly a
sign of weakness no it's definitely a
sign of weakness okay if you want to see
your partner screwed by somebody else
I'm gonna go with you're a weak person
and and you have no idea what morality
or love really are I'm pretty stringent
on the whole don't be happy with your
partner having sex with others Leigh
says this fantasy has been around as
long as marriage and sexuality by the
way Leigh is written a book called
insatiable wives but we're
hearing more and more about these days
and more people are rejecting the social
stigma about this fantasy the authors
didn't actually talk to any heterosexual
couples the the study is titled the
psychology of gay men's loading
fantasies and the only people who
interviewed for the study we're 580 men
who self-identified as gay but what did
CNN do they extrapolated the study's
findings across the board of course they
extrapolated the findings across the
board because they want to pretend the
men and women are exactly the same
anybody who believes then women men and
women are precisely the same when it
comes to sexual fantasies like you know
why men don't care about being cuckolded
with other men because men don't care
about promiscuity if the deal is I get
to have sex with whomever I want
they're probably willing to let their
partner have sex with whomever that
partner wants ok well men are men ok gay
men are still men men when it comes to
sex are pigs and so it's not
particularly shocked that men who are
involved in other relationships with
other men tend to be more prominent and
promiscuous than men who are involved in
relationships with women by numbers they
says overall our research found that for
the most part cuckolding tends to be a
positive fantasy in behavior it doesn't
appear to be evidence of disturbance of
an unhealthy relationship or of
disregard from one's partner one of the
authors leigh miller appears to spoken
to heterosexuals about cuckolding he
said that 58 percent of men and 33% of
women had at least thought about the
practice but didn't get much information
on whether they had tried it or whether
they thought that it would be a good
idea
or whether they were the ones being
cuckolded but because of the practice
isn't quite as taboo in the gay
community he says it might be a little
more prevalent among gay men savage of
course is enthusiastic about this he
says it's not cuckolding if there isn't
an element of humiliations aggradation
or denial our erotic imaginations have
the ability to turn shame lemons into
delicious pink lemonade
dan Savage so I'm so glad that CNN
decided to cover this fringe behavior
and then pretend that it applies equally
to everyone men and women male-female
relationships pretending that
relationships between men and men are
the same as relationships between men
and women is patently insane if you've
never met a man this makes perfect sense
to you if you were born on a desert
island and you've never met a person of
the opposite sex maybe this makes
perfect sense to you if you have ever
met another man in your man you know
that this the idea that any relationship
you have with another man is equivalent
to a relationship that you would have
with a woman is totally bizarre it's
totally crazy but this is one of the
things that the left has put upon us is
this notion that all distinctions
between men and women are obviously
social constructs that is obviously and
eminently untrue okay other things that
I hate so
now a chicago man is accused of sexually
assaulting two six-year-olds in an
eight-year-old on repeated occasions why
did he tell the police officers he told
them that he was quote a nine year old
trapped in an adult's body there it is
38 year old Roman Rose Joseph Roman
charged with repeated predatory criminal
sexual assault the numerous attacks
began in 2015 continued until earlier
this month Roman has reportedly
confessed to some of these some of the
attacks to authorities the victims were
the daughters of his friends so he is
now identifying as a as a child in a
man's body well I don't see why he can't
do that I mean we've been told that you
can be a woman in a man's body or a man
in a woman's body so it seems to me a
lot easier to get to the point that you
say that I have the mentality of a nine
year old have the develop brain of a
nine year old as opposed to I have the
develop brain of a woman inside a man's
body there's just as much evidence for
one as for the other meaning none so so
I don't see why everybody is the
anti-trans age I sort of made this point
in one of the famous YouTube videos that
I did it was based on the speech that I
did where transgender advocate got up
and asked why I would not say man was
woman and I asked her what her age was
and she said she's 21 I said why aren't
you 60 and she said because I'm not well
this guy's not nine years old either
even though he's even though he says he
is okay other than one more thing that I
hate then we'll get to the mailbag the
final thing that I hate here is a UN
Ambassador nikki Haley is now being
accused of having an affair with
President Trump okay I'm getting really
really annoyed with the with the
foolishness of the of the left that
suggests that anytime anytime a woman of
power is in Republican position it's
because she slept her way to the top and
nikki Haley is now being accused kind of
quasi by Michael Wolff he appeared on
HBO's Real Time with Bill Maher and he
said he was absolutely sure the Trump is
having an affair which would not be a
giant surprise he then say he then said
that careful readers of his book could
find a clue saying now that I told you
when you hit that paragraph you're gonna
say bingo
he says reader it's a political says
readers quickly honed in on a single
sentence in the runaway bestseller which
has been criticized for everything from
sloppy copy editing to gross factual
inaccuracies Wolff writes the president
had been spending a notable amount of
private time with Haley on Air Force One
and was seen to be grooming her for a
national political future so now the
entire media has jumped on this rumor
suggesting that perhaps nikki Haley is
sleeping with Trump again there's no
evidence to this what so I
Haley says that this of course is
absolutely not true she's I've literally
been on Air Force One one once there
were several people in the room when I
was there and Haley said he says I've
been talking a lot with the president
the Oval about my political future I've
never once talked to the president about
my future I'm never alone with him
so the idea these things come out that's
a problem it goes to a bigger issue we
need to be conscious of at every point
in my life I've noticed that if you
speak your mind and you're strong about
it and you say what you believe there's
a small percentage of people that resent
it and the way they try to deal with it
is to try and throw arrows lies or not
she said I saw this as a legislator I
saw this when I was governor I see it
now I see them do it to other women and
the thing is when women work they
prioritize they focus and they believe
that they're gonna do something do it
right
others see that as too ambitious are
stepping out of line the truth is we
need to continue to do our job and if
that means they consider it stepping out
of line fine and this is why nikki Haley
is very popular because she doesn't take
this kind of crap it is insane the media
I've been running with this rumor but
you know the media had nothing to say
for years apparently the New York Times
story out today it's breaking story and
that a senior adviser to Hillary
Clinton's 2008 presidential campaign who
was accused of repeatedly sexually
harassing a young subordinate was kept
on the campaign at Hillary's direct
request according to four people
familiar with what took place so the
left fits happily willing to to defend
me to is also happily willing to accused
nikki Haley of sleeping her way to the
top and also to overlook Hillary Clinton
letting a campaign aide off the hook who
was apparently sexually harassing young
woman young women they the campaign
adviser was burned stridor instead
strider was docked several weeks of pay
in order to undergo counseling and the
young woman was moved to a new job so
just class all the way around for the
left well done before I go any further I
do want to mention one more quick thing
that I hate then we'll jump right in the
mailbags that gives people a chance to
actually get back into the stream Barack
Obama took a picture with Louis
Farrakhan and the media hit it so
there's that okay I'm just gonna put
that out there that there is this
picture that exists Louis Farrakhan is
one of the world's worst anti-semites
he's an absolute piece of human debris
and Barack Obama was happy to take
pictures with him because Barack Obama
was never a moderate he was always a
radical we said so at the time it was
denied by everyone and they're all liars
and terrible people okay so now time for
the mailbag so if you have questions
send them in write this instance okay so
now let's start with Daniel he says hey
Ben do you think the government should
be allowed to force someone to buy car
insurance when a car is purchased how
can the government force me to buy
something I do not want so the reason
that the government is allowed to force
you to buy car insurance
when the car is purchased is because
there's an externality so the government
is allowed to regulate products that
have an automatic externality when you
drive a car if you get in a car accident
the insurance is not to protect you the
insurances protect the other drivers if
you a bunch of drivers on the streets
who don't have car insurance and then
they hit you and they damage your car or
they kill you
then you've created a serious problem
now there's a possible solution to that
that doesn't involve car insurance and
that is that you actually hold people
accountable under tort law and you get
rid of bankruptcy law right that would
be the alternative but if the idea is
that there is a privilege that is
driving and that privilege exists
because they're externalities to the
privileged you don't have a right to
drive you have a privilege to drive and
that privilege comes along with
externalities then it's not wrong to
have the government make you buy car
insurance if the government makes you
buy health insurance is different
because there it's not about
externalities there it's about you are
responsible for your own health and that
isn't that that is creating costs but
that's on you right the cost is on you
so if you don't have health insurance
people theoretically you could say we
don't want to cover you which is what
people do the same is not true of car
insurance if you hit me in an accident
then I don't have a choice as to whether
I wanted you to hit me in the accident
Seth does mr. Shapiro I listened to your
debate with Sam Harris and I heard you
repeat the question how do you go from
an is to a nod a couple of times
would you mind elaborating on that more
is this begging the question of how
morality came into existence and the art
is the moral implication the is comes
from the evolutionary scientific
perspective derived from observation of
suppose in fact great debate by the way
love listening to these conversations so
I'm glad they enjoyed the conversation
the point that I was making was a point
that was originally made by David Hume
he basically suggested that you cannot
look at the universe and then just say
that because things are a certain way
then you ought to act a certain way
there is no connection for example
between the way the universe is
constructed and morality it constructed
you can't you could construct a thousand
different types of morality there's
nothing that dictates they have to go
from what is to what ought to be or how
you ought to act now this has
significant ramifications for scientific
materialists like Sam no Sam has a
suggestion his suggestion is well if we
knew everything in the known universe
then what else would we need to know to
construct a morality I had two
objections that one is when he says
construct immorality he's assuming a
freedom of choice that I'm not sure that
his philosophy allows to exist I mean
this is a real debate between
Sammy and I don't want to misconstrue
his position or misstate his position so
he can read his book on freewill if you
think I am doing so and get his his more
detailed perspective that's problem
number one that I had and I was trying
to point that out to Sam and I think we
were talking past each other and problem
number two is that Sam says well there's
really three problems he says that if
you know everything in existence then
you could be able to determine what's
right and what's wrong I don't think
that's true because people have a unique
capacity to look at the same set of
facts and draw different conclusions and
then problem number three is if you knew
everything in the universe you would be
God right I mean the premise that I use
is that God does know everything in the
universe and therefore he was capable of
constructing morality so you're just
assuming that eventually human beings
will be able to become gods and I'm not
sure that I buy into that premise but
that is the is of--this ting ssin that
is not distinction can be bridged in two
ways one is with revelation so you
actually have a deus ex machina god
suggest either Christ suggests or or the
Jew or the Judaic God at Sinai suggests
here are the rules right he says you
know you can't get from the is the odd
so let me give you a hand with that
here's what you ought to do and here's
what you ought not to do right that's
revelation and then there's the the
Greek reason argument that suggests you
can look at what is and gets a lot by
saying what is the purpose right what is
the Telos you've heard me mention the
Greek word Telos before Tilos is the
suggestion that there is a purpose that
is embedded in the universe so it is so
for example well it's the the the
example that's typically used is I'm
wearing a watch right the watch that I'm
wearing is made to tell time it is
either good or tell it's howling time or
it is bad at telling time what dictates
whether the watch is virtuous is whether
the watch fulfills its purpose and you
can look at the universe and say what
does man made for man is made to use his
reason because his reason is different
from what animals have and so he should
be using his reason and whatever is in
service to reason is good and whatever
is not in service to reason is immoral
this sort of the the Greek view of why
reason is important and what virtue is
built to do so those are the two ways to
reach it to reach purpose to reach aught
from is the West has rejected both of
those in in modern times and I think
because of that we've landed on these
aimless shores with people telling that
telling you that you can construct your
own purpose and we've we failed that
tyler's has been what was the best way
you studied for the LSAT any good study
books you'd recommend
well actually I used test masters and I
openly say so test master is
program so consider that an endorsement
test masters and also advertise with us
because as long as I'm giving you plugs
you may as well it pass the money for it
Rock'em Emma Cooper min says hey Ben I
was wondering what your opinion is on
making her items served in the Israeli
military and if you lived in Israel
which political party would you vote for
I've said for years that coloratum
should serve in the Israeli military
that if you have universal military
service you should not be able to opt
out of Israeli military service simply
because you say you are studying if I
were a secular Jew in Israel and my kid
were going to fight in the army and your
kid were studying in yeshiva and the
suggestion was that your kid was doing
as much for the State of Israel as my
kid is doing I would say that's
ridiculous and self-serving now if you
want to say even if you wanted to say
that you think that there's a spiritual
component to study that does not exist
for for fighting and that you need a few
people studying that's one thing but to
say that everybody who wants to study
gets out of military service as a cop
out in the same way that it was a cop
out during the Vietnam War to say that
everybody in college got out of military
service I think that that's that's a
foolish thing I've always been a great
admirer of what they call the history of
vote these are these are yeshiva x'
where people study Torah but at the same
time they are serving in the armies
they're doing both and Joshua says hey
Ben you mentioned that when you went to
Disneyland you had met a bunch of your
fans does constant recognition and
requests for photos ever get irritating
and are most people generally respectful
if they see you're busy with family
everybody I've met like it's universal
everybody's been very respectful of my
time and my privacy which is great and
in fact I've made it a habit to ask
people if they want pictures because
people are very shy very often about
asking for pictures I'm not trying to be
self aggrandizing I'm just I know that
the people want pictures they're trying
not to be rude people have been really
really good about it I don't find it
irritating I find it flattering I'm glad
that people listen to the show I'm glad
that people take my ideas seriously and
if they do I think that that's that's
wonderful it makes a difference mark
says I know it's probably the Trump
suggested immigration plan from Thursday
won't go anywhere that said if somehow
this did pass from Congress how'd that
affect the GOP for the midterms and
Beyond so it seemed to me that it may
help Trump's approval with independents
and liberals as it is quite generous for
immigrants also for Republicans building
wall and enshrining law and for
migration fixes would overshadow the
downsides to this possible legislation
well it's hard to predict how it affect
turnout
usually off your elections the base is
what has to turn out the base may not be
happy with this and so you might see a
drop in turnout in a general election
for Trump's 2020 it would probably help
him for 2020 he would look more moderate
people who are independents would would
probably flock to him more often
conservatives could point to the victory
but for the midterms I think would
probably hurt him in the short room in
the short run Matz has been what ethical
theory do you most often hold to and
which ethical theory do you think is the
weakest also where do you land on your
rip throws at dilemma
so the ethical theory that I most often
hold to is the is the judeo-christian
Biblical ethical theory which suggests
that there is an objective good and
there is an objective bad and and the
and the notion that you can construct
your own good and bad is is foolish so I
agree with that utilitarianism I yeah
everyone intends to be a little bit of
utilitarian but I think the
utilitarianism is is open-ended and
depends on what you define as your
hierarchy of utility so it's open to
various different rebukes I think Kant's
categorical imperative is open to a
bunch of different rebukes because there
are plenty of things that I would be
willing to do to other people and have
them done to me that other people
wouldn't be willing to have done to them
I think that the categorical imperative
is a little bit is a little bit weak so
when the Europe throws a limo which I to
be honest with you just looked up again
because I've been going through the
Republic in my head is filled with with
things the Reptoids LMO found in Plato's
dialogue is where Socrates asks Europe
throw is the pie is the pious person
loved by the gods because it is pious or
is the pious is doing pious things is
piety loved by the gods because it is
pious or is it pious because it is loved
by the gods so in other words it's got
above morality or is morality above God
so my answer is that God is above
morality but we believe in the
judeo-christian tradition that God has
done us the great service of embedding
morality in his own action so God
doesn't have to be moral he's God he can
do whatever he wants he's all-powerful
but Judaism says that God also acts in
moral fashion this doesn't mean we
always understand the way that he is
acting but this is the entire reason
that for example Abraham argues with God
right that God and it's that Abraham
says to God would you kill would you
destroy the city if there are 50
righteous people 40 righteous people 30
20 10 and the reason these bargaining
with God over this is because he's
trying to remind God of his own morality
right that's the idea here Moses does
the same thing Moses says to God if you
do this you will be perceived by the
world as immoral so why would you do
this when God talks about wiping out the
Jewish people in the desert Moses says
this so
the the idea here is that God is about
morality but has bonded himself to a
morality which we can which we can
identify a shadow of we can't identify
all of it we can see God's back we can
see his front right in the section of
the Torah where where Moses asked to see
God's face meaning I want to see your
logic for the universe God says you can
no one can see my face and live you can
see my back meaning you can see the
shadow of my morality but I'm never
going to allow you to see my entire math
of how this works so the so the answer
is piety is loved by God because it is
piety
it is not piety just because it is loved
by God God is God is above morality but
it's bounded himself to a certain sense
of morality Rihanna
says hi Ben I recently listened to
Tucker Carlson apparently China has
recently successfully cloned a monkey
they're heralding this is a crucial step
to cloning humans if we limited human
cloning to only clone and replace
damaged organs I don't see an inherent
problem with it however I do see an
inherent problem with attempting to
regulate enforce a policy limiting
cloning to only that what's your take
well I agree that we should limit
cloning to only organ cloning for for
those purposes I think trying to clone a
human life is the there are serious
moral issues with it beyond the question
of the selfishness of wanting to clone
yourself right and or the or the idea
that you're preserved like are you let
look for this way you have grandma
grandmas about to die you decide you're
gonna clone her and when you clone her
she is presumably going to come out the
she's going to be birth right you take
her DNA
you know inserting an egg and now you
have cloned grandma presumably she comes
out as a baby because she's not gonna be
born as a 99 year old person so if
that's the case then are you now putting
on that person all of your preconceived
notions about grandmas that person
actually a fully independent person it
raises some serious ethical dilemmas we
are kind of far scientifically from
cloning a human being at least in
healthy ways even when we've cloned
animals even one who cloned animals the
animals
my understanding is have not tended to
live as long as the originals so I think
there's still some kinks to be worked
out in that process
Bailey says hey Ben what do you think is
the major cause of the rapid evolution
of the left into such an oppressive
ideology over the last couple of years I
think that the left has has fallen
deeper and deeper into a victim
mentality that has forced them into in
to tribalism of the highest order that
victim mentality is now manifesting
really strong I think the Barack Obama's
election was part of this I think Obama
had such an opportunity to unify the
country and when Obama decided instead
to exploit political divisions between
us for his own political gain I think
that people Rahm Don to that and it made
the country a whole hell of a lot worse
I think we were much more unified in
2007 with all that was going on then
then we are today and I think a lot of
that has to do with with Democrats
embracing polarities not only among
politics and political opinions but
polarities among tribal groups tribal
identity groups they're using identity
as a substitute for logic reason or even
political positioning okay so we will be
back here tomorrow well no we won't it's
tomorrow Saturday it's beyond the week
excellent okay we will be back here on
Monday and have a great weekend we'll
see you then
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing